he threatened me I'll call the police
again Minnie drivers bitter feud with
her next-door neighbour has gone viral
and only I talked to Minnie today to get
her side of the story I have definitely
lost my cool I've never been that angry
with another human being it destroyed my
property The Good Will Hunting star is
at war with her 74 year old neighbor
Daniel Perlmutter over this shared
driveway and gate Perlmutter is suing
alleging she changed the gate code
blocked vehicles from entering and tried
to run him down with her BMW it is an
egregious allegation these kind of
disputes happen all the time but mini
says now her 7 year old is terrified of
the man who was building that house
Henry's scared to come back to the house
he sleeps in my bed and we lock the door
this is my property you know you're a
sick Mormon
he's blend smoking my son and my nephew
and nieces faces cussing at my son at me
crazy misogynistic remarks this is my
confident wonderful child
who
it was great I'm happy and it goes to a
great school and has great friends Henry
said there must be other people who
don't like him and I said yes the must
and there are Perlmutter also believes
that she smashed black paint filled baby
food jars against his Hollywood Hills
home
I would not stoop to breaking the law to
vandalism of any kind we have footage oh
that your nanny shot and explained to me
what happens in that footage my nanny
was trying to get out to go pick my son
up his cars and his trucks were blocking
the driveway she asked them to move they
wouldn't move he he goes very quickly to
shouting extremely abusive things I
would ask him just to stop if only from
my kid you know coming here getting a
chance to see everything and also here
many side of the story it really does
put everything into context it's a
mother concerned about her child think
of that little boy I just hope they can
keep the peace and I hope the court date
will happen soon it's a tough situation
right there